did I hear that you supplied cocktail
Whitney Houston yeah that was crazy can
you tell us anything more about that
because that's an insane footnote it was
like the weirdest [__] story ever I
used to buy weed from a guy every week I
go over there this is before legal
marijuana [__] yeah he knew I did Coke
and he would ask me hey man I got a
client that could really use your help
but I already knew like
whenever somebody comes up to you and
says I have something for you like that
it sounds good but it could be a cop
yeah it could be a thousand things so I
just brushed them off you know nah I'm
okay and finally one day it's like
listen my friend really needs help he's
a tour manager and his client really
needs this coke can you at least meet
with him and talk to him he'll pay you
top dollar I'm like okay
and I met with the guy in in the
conversation he goes I need I could buy
like an ounce of coke for me every day
I'm like okay but I'm going I'm doing
time if I get into I was already into
comedy already you know and I'm like I
don't want to do time now for Coke
let's give it a run I go how about I
sell you a half ounce to start off with
and it started small after about three
weeks I would go because he was coming
every other [__] day
draft ounce of coat and finally I go
what the [__] guy what do you do he's
like I'm Whitney Houston's poor manager
I'll tell you something Whitney Cummings
no they're here they're here
I didn't even know Whitney did blow they
they're here they're here uh doing an
album her and Bobby Brown yeah yeah so
they were getting after it they were
going after it and I but I never saw her
like I would love to tell you I partied
with them and no no no that was [__]
I never saw them then I didn't they they
were there for like I don't know maybe
November
what is the Grammys
in February was the Grammys and I'm like
these [__] have been calling me
every day for the Grammys what are they
gonna do
that we're gonna want half of Columbia
I'll never forget that Grammy weekend I
was hosting at the store and I went to
the bathroom and Tom Cruise was in the
bathroom
and he looked at me because you're
pretty funny out there or something
something about short came out like in
the bathroom he was pretty short yeah he
was in there with his wife at the time
the redhead oh they want the House of
Blues for an Oscar party a Grammy party
and I remember that night I went home
and I'm like wow the Grammys these
[__] didn't call me all weekend
I went home and the next morning at
seven o'clock my page is going off and
it's the manager and he goes hey man
sorry we didn't get a hold of you we
were busy can you get us something this
morning it was seven in the [__]
morning wow I'm like God damn okay I
called the Martell cartel that's why I
got my coke from the Martell cartel and
they're like come over at seven in the
morning and at this time he was still
buying like a half ounce and sometimes
he would buy an extra eighth and I was
putting a little bit of cutting it
making money off the coke and I take a
gram out of this [__] you know
well that morning they wanted like
[__] an ounce and a half
and they came to my house and that was
the only time I saw Whitney oh wow
seriously showed up yeah wow she was
very sweet very nice I didn't do coke
with them you know I loved to tell you I
was there with Bobby Brown they were and
they I sold them to Coke and that's the
last time
93. ah no no I was living with my wife
already so
it had to be like late 90s early 2000s
wow and that was the last one yeah why
would she show up
because they were out the night before I
could tell you they didn't even go home
I never slept no I could tell you more
on this story which I will when the
cameras aren't all where they were
coming from whose house they were coming
from that night wow oh okay and who else
is in the car yeah oh okay it was pretty
like wow